President Trump is really furious did
you know this he is furious about the
FBI raid on his personal lawyer yeah
and these leaks have been coming out
just about how mad he is this is the
latest it was reported that President
Trump is doing nothing right now this is
true but anger this is in the papers but
angrily fuming eating and watching TV
they say that's all he's doing
yeah they say he's fuming and just
eating and watching TV in other words it
sounds like Trump is turning into a
trump voter
[Applause]
he's he's got the old remote that clicks
the one from the 70s
Mark Zuckerberg testified before
Congress again today
part two just as riveting as the first
one Mark Zuckerberg yes he completed day
two of his congressional testimony about
security breaches yes I things got a
little tense when Zuckerberg referred to
each senator by their pin number did you
know this this is true while he was
testifying yesterday Facebook stock went
up and Mark Zuckerberg just during his
testimony made three billion dollars
yeah yeah yeah yeah when he heard that
Tom from MySpace said I will also
testify I'll be right there
made six hundred bucks
House Speaker Paul Ryan said he is not
seeking re-election because he wants to
spend more time with his kids not gonna
seek reelection Paul Ryan yeah Ryan said
as a dad there comes a time when you
want to be there to take away their
health care impersonal
take that former House Speaker John
Boehner did you hear this John Boehner
has joined the board of a marijuana
company today he said that his this is a
quote his thinking on cannabis has
evolved yeah yeah speeders happy yeah
yeah yeah he said his this is a real
quote he said his thinking on cannabis
has a vault Boehner said yeah I can only
mean really one thing his grandson
showed him how to use a bong this
morning this morning DEA officials did
you hear this have seized 500 pounds of
meth concealed inside Disney figurines
500 pounds of meth in Disney speak yeah
which explains why goofy is missing all
but two teeth
you